if a writer has three ideas how do they
know which one to choose oh well
um I think it depends on sort of what
they want out of the writing project
right so there I think there are a few
criteria you can look to and it's a
really personal decision I also think
you don't ever have to throw an idea
away if you have three that you want to
write you know that means you're really
just choosing which one you're going to
write next and then you can always have
the other two on Deck right
um I personally think that you should
you know sort of gauge the concept and
make sure that each idea you're weighing
is a strong enough idea to be a
screenplay that's the first thing but if
all that's equal
um I think you you should look at what
you want to get out of the out of the
project so is it helping you you know
learn a new skill in your in your
writing kind of toolkit is it um helping
you advance your career in a particular
way is it you know filling out your
portfolio of writing samples
um
so that is helpful to to kind of gauge
what do I want this to do for me so that
you're not you know no writing is wasted
it's not wasted time but so that you're
getting the most out of of the project
that you're going to write
um and then also if you know the ending
I think that that's very helpful
um because that you know
sometimes if you start a writing project
without knowing the ending
that can be a longer more frustrating
process to to outline that but if you
kind of you know how this story ends the
outlining of it the figuring out kind of
how the the plot progresses all the
steps in the plot and everything that's
a little bit easier because you know
what destination you're headed towards
so that's interesting when you said that
you've you've actually outlined four
people once you see their finished
script if you see someone who's hung up
on the ending do you get them to that
point and then say okay now I mean I
realize you're not figuring out the
ending for them but do do you outline up
until that point and then maybe that
helps them through it well if I'm if I'm
making an outline from a finished draft
that someone's you know given me to read
um I outline exactly what they have in
the draft so if their ending isn't
working or if it isn't complete
um and I have read scripts like that I
will outline exactly what they have and
then we'll talk about you know what's
missing here is it is that the ending is
totally gone and you need to figure out
what that is or is it just that you know
you've you've sort of wrapped up the
plot but it's not it's really not
complete or you know resolving things as
it needs to so I mean that's kind of
um just a normal a normal day in in kind
of doing the script consults is lot of
times the ending needs work so we'll
just talk about like how can we
strengthen that sure but that sounds
really helpful just again as it's easier
for someone to come in and organize
someone's space than if you have all
these personal mementos and like oh I
can't get rid of this I can't get rid of
that oh my grandmother gave me this but
if the organizer comes in and says how
about we put this over here it yeah it
sounds like it's much easier yeah and I
think that I think that that's such a
good analogy because that is probably
what it feels like as well you know if
you've written a draft and you're like
here are the scenes that I love and I
want them to be in there but you know
something about it isn't working there
is that feeling of like I'm attached to
these things but I don't know how to
organize them in a way that they need to
in order for it to kind of like make
sense for everyone else as well you know
sure yeah sure and then you open the
closet door and everything falls yes and
hence the screenplay might be really
jumbled and if we put it if we make
sense to the to the the viewer or the
reader yeah yeah and when when I go in
there it's like you know I can sort of
outline based on what they already have
have and then we can talk about okay so
here's what we have so far and then
here's what the third act needs to do
like here's you know how it needs to
resolve the plot and wrap up character
Arc and all that stuff so what are we
missing and then we can kind of fill in
the holes you know
what is brain dump oh um that's just
something I'm sure other people use it
in different ways but it's something
that I think is a useful exercise to do
at the beginning of sort of your your
story breaking process you know when you
come up with an idea
um and you haven't really done much to
shape it yet I think it's really useful
to just sort of sit down and write down
everything you know about that idea
because you end up capturing stuff that
you maybe didn't realize you knew about
it or thought about it and then you also
sort of end up capturing like what you
love about that idea when you're in that
moment of still being in love with it so
that later on when you're writing the
script and you inevitably get to that
frustrating part where you get stuck or
you don't know what happens next and you
you know are feeling like why did I
start writing this you can kind of go
back to that brain dump and remember
like what made me fall in love with this
idea to begin with or what was it about
this idea that you know in spite hired
me how did I want people to feel
what were my hopes and aspirations for
this project you know before I went down
started Down The Long Road of actually
writing it so yeah
so if I have let's say a notebook
um and it's my idea for this movie or
this character I'm just kind of like
this is my notebook where I'm going to
put The Good the Bad and the Ugly about
this character the story anything I can
think of yeah um and I think it's
probably different for every project and
for every writer like what comes to mind
I think it's useful to give yourself a
little bit of structure you know some
parameters around the brain dump but
really it should be whatever you know
about your your project at that point in
time so I just think you know write down
anything that um where the idea came
from anything that inspires you about
the idea or how do you see this finished
movie like what other movies would it
would would it be like
um what's the soundtrack sound like are
there any songs that give you that
feeling that you want the movie to have
talking about characters for sure like
who's the main character if you know
that
um what's that character like
uh what kind of relationships does that
character have who are the people in his
or her life
um you know kind of anything that you
sort of come to the table with when
you're just getting you know inspired by
that idea like just starting to sort of
gather everything that you know about it
that you're going to start shaping into
the story eventually like because you
know at the beginning it's like you have
a jumble of ideas I think you have oh
this would be a great scene or you know
oh I think it ends like this maybe with
this final shot I don't know how we get
there but it's them riding off into the
sunset or
um you know I I don't know who this
character is but I think that there's a
guy who you know had this background or
has this you know affectation and I
wonder how he got to be that way and so
it's just a it's just a way for you to
start to gather kind of like all of
those little tidbits that you think
might belong to this story put them all
in one place so that you don't have that
that feeling of like you know that
nervous feeling of like I'm gonna forget
this idea and I don't know where it goes
yet and so you're all stressed out about
trying to work it into the story you can
put it all in one place and just hold it
there so that as you're working through
kind of that development process you can
always go back to it and reference it
come up with those ideas that you had at
one time that maybe you'd forgotten
about so
so let's suppose
um I was Eric Roth and I was thought of
this idea for this Forrest Gump
character or based on a book whatever
and and I thought okay here's my here's
my notebook with forest in it and so
southern town
um loving mom uh you know definitely
health problems with with his legs
different things and then meets Jenny
um meets Bubba all these different
things meets Captain Dan you know you
know different fights different things
and his goal of being sort of this just
this theme through his life of of being
in like these interesting places at the
right time and helping people he's
almost like a helper yeah um and so
um I'm just kind of like getting it out
this is Forest this is there wasn't
really anything bad about him but these
are some of the things that that make up
this Forest character yeah and hopefully
you know if you're working on that
project or you're inspired enough to
kind of sit down and start to gather
your thoughts hopefully there's
something about who that character is
that you really like right or that
interests you at least and so so those
are the things that I think you should
focus on because those are going to be
the things that sort of help you later
on in the story you know like
um having those touchstones of like oh
yeah I remember I really wanted this
character to have this particular
feeling or to maybe have this particular
Arc to learn this lesson across this
story
um so yeah I I don't even know
um if you I guess if you know that much
about your story it's great and write it
all down but you don't even have to try
to you know shape it in the brain dump
process I think
um
I wouldn't put pressure on yourself to
try to come up with like oh this is
First Act stuff and this is you know
where the story goes from there it's
just kind of whatever you know whatever
Sparks your interest when you think
about that particular idea
um and I always like the the sort of
prompts or questions you ask yourself
about like
what do how do I see this in its
finished form even if it's not specifics
but it's like how do I want people to
feel when they see it or you know what
does the soundtrack sound like is a good
one because it's like What feelings does
it give you when you hear the you know
music or what music makes you think of
this idea or make you feel the way this
idea makes you feel
um and then I also one other thing that
I think is really helpful to do in the
kind of brain dump process is think
about what the story means to you
um because that helps you start to
narrow in on the theme of the story
which I think is one of those things
that like it really intimidates a lot of
writers it feels like oh I have to come
up with some big profound statement
um but really you're just trying to come
up with like the the mean what does it
mean to you right like what's the sort
of takeaway message or you know big idea
that this story imparts and that can be
really daunting and intimidating so if
you do it in the brain dump process
where you're just sort of free-flowing
and brainstorming
um it gives you kind of a pressure free
and environment to kind of think about
like what does the story mean like what
kind of lesson would this character
learn or what kind of lesson could this
experience teach someone you know
um and what's the story about for me
like what does it what does it sort of
mean to me you know inside that I that I
kind of want to get at or explore in the
story
okay so I wouldn't necessarily know
maybe all of these things when I
mentioned Lieutenant Dan and these
things I would just know that it's a
character maybe the odds were kind of
stacked against him but he didn't really
have a mean streak in him he didn't need
to get revenge on people yeah or maybe
what have been done to him or or he was
still just a kind-hearted guy yeah and I
think maybe if you were developing that
story idea right
um in the brain dump process you might
not know the specifics about those other
characters but you might say okay I have
this main character that I'm really
interested in I think his name's Forrest
Gump and he's this type of guy right
he's a he's such a kind person he
doesn't have a mean bone in his body and
the kinds of people that he could run
into that would create conflict and help
him kind of move through the story might
be you know someone who he's in love
with who doesn't reciprocate right and
so he has to contend with that set of
emotions
um maybe he has kind of a mentor
character that he meets in the unlikely
place of in the in the military it's
been a long time since I saw that so I
don't remember if uh Dan is the mentor
but maybe he meets somebody who's very
Gruff and sort of the opposite of him
personality wise right uh maybe he meets
Bubba who in some ways is similar like
sort of innocent and kind of sees the
world in a particular way and so by
pairing up with that person you know
these are the kinds of things that he
might experience or lessons that he
might learn or situations he might find
himself in you know